Jim Nantz said to join us brought to you
by Vineyard Vines and we got to see Jim
gave us some gifts there Vineyard Vines
he's got a store that opened at Pebble
Beach last Wednesday and steps from the
putting green across from the lodge
he is mr. Pebble Beach he's Jim Nantz
hello friends how are you
I'm very blue though because I had all
kinds of plans for us this year during
the AT&T and now I hear that the trip is
scratched yeah you know the Jim Nantz
breakfast the the par-3 contest that
mclovin won
yeah we were we were disappointed that
we can't join you out there Jim we
always appreciate the hospitality which
is we might have to organize something
on the side just a boy's trip out to the
Pebble Beach and come hang out and do a
little bit more than we did tournament a
week anyway so I like that little
mischief I like that how about it how
about a sleepover Jim Nancy's house yeah
yeah tell me how the Manning Brady
backyard visit happened you know it's
kind of last-minute I wanted her to be
is I in on many respects there is
biggish biggest show right I mean it's
the two of them together I mean it would
be gold but they were going to be
together for an event to have a beach I
got a call I was on the East Coast I
wasn't there I was at Hartford doing the
Travelers Championship and they said hey
would you mind if we did this and of
course we're glad to have them it was
pretty funny and then you know they were
they were trying to figure out the
password the code for your your gate
there I thought it was they bad some fun
at your expense
well there were some good minds in there
and I don't know who's responsible for
but it was run a clever and behind you
for about five months was that they had
shot it on the property and up by the
point three were McLovin of course is
the king and I had no idea about the
shenanigans and what they did at the
gate and and then they let me in on it
in December and said you know we need
you to record a couple of lives I said
what do I have to do with it you'll see
since I got hold of feedback on it was
it was good fun I was trying to explain
to these guys and our audience when
you're up on the podium when it's chaos
there's so much going on around you you
know you're interchangeable guests there
there's confetti you got a time element
you got a producer in your ear you're
trying to ask enough questions to
satisfy everybody then throw it back to
the studio I said that it's always been
the toughest thing I've had to learn is
to be able to talk to somebody and
remember what you're saying and what
they're saying but also somebody is
talking to you in your ear while you're
doing that can you give the audience an
idea of what that was like in Kansas
City with Travis Kelce and company Dan
you have to fight and you almost missed
out on that because you were saying okay
we got to go back to the studio and you
just put that microphone in front of
Kelsey and you as we all know never give
up the microphone in a situation like
that you cannot do that but I have to
tell you I was insubordinate their
voices in your ear I had gym rat cop who
I really love and I'm sure he had people
behind him that were screaming to get
off the air and Jim kept saying as I was
talking to batch revolves this is that
this is it now I'm working past that and
I see time standing there silent Matthew
and I see Travis Travis only tipped me
off that he wanted to say something no
what am I going to do if just one day MC
championship I'm going to blow
these guys off so I mean I wasn't
exactly sure what the rush was and I'm
really good at following instructions
but on this one occasion I think I said
something about I've got to get it back
to the studio yeah
hey guys congratulations and China just
said thank you and that of course Travis
just went off and it made the whole
thing great how many times have you done
that at the Super Bowl where you're
hosting 16 AFC championships I've done
34 NCAA Championships I've done a lot of
regional finals I've done because I've
been at the Masters 34 years but 32
years I've been there for a completely
different ceremony than a butler cabin
but Travis is dormant pretty darn cool I
actually have to confess when when I
grabbed the mic and you know hang on for
dear life as you said because you got
the network injured hands when he
started to say the word might be to my
mind and I I did think someone in that
millisecond there was a synapse or
something that was telling me oh my gosh
we're talking we're talking to Jim Nantz
of course the lead play-by-play voice
for the NFL on CBS the Masters in Final
Four I know you sign off Fox has the
Super Bowl did you feel mixed emotions
here with Tony Romo's contract situation
didn't really think about it at that
point obviously it's something that I'm
well aware of and Tony and I talk about
all the time and I certainly hopeful
prayerful that have worked out and I
there's nothing much more I can say that
I I wish for him that the best that he
can do whatever that might be but it is
love that CBS buy a lot of people no one
more so than then yours truly and
he knows how I feel about it but I'm not
going to apply any pressure and
hopefully this will be something that we
can do together for a long long time you
know we're just getting started we're
three years into it I'm saying goodbye
to the football season look I'm grateful
we get to do the AFC Championship it's
big deal and you know we alternate every
third year with the big game we just had
it this past February and oddly enough
next year we're going to actually come
up in two years time because we made the
switch the trade with with NBC so that
we move up a year this had to do with
the Winter Olympics yeah and NBC having
the Olympics and the Super Bowl falling
on the same year NBC didn't want that so
they proposed that we trade out but Los
Angeles Super Bowl that we had that we
possessed for Tampa Bay so we're going
to Tampa next year at NBC the following
year we'll take what would have been our
Super Bowl in LA I've said this before
to this audience that then I know Tony
gets a lot of credit and he's unique and
people love that style and it's fun but
he puts you on an island like your
ability to be able to grab what he
leaves for you and then get back to the
play in time to call it in real time and
then allow him to go sort of rogue a
little bit with his thoughts it's it's
not lost on me Jim and I'm certainly I'm
certain that there are other
play-by-play voices who look at that and
say that's a real real talent to be able
to do that and make it feel seamless and
that's what if Tony would leave you you
know there very few people like you in
this business and to be able to do that
and I think that you complement each
other so well and it just it's a unique
sound and it's rare when we have unique
sounds when it comes to play-by-play in
color well that was really nice what you
said Dan you know how much I respect you
and your observations and you understand
the business but I got to tell you when
we're on the air it's two guys who
happen to have a very strong friendship
who are just talking now if I'm playing
jump a little bit on some of the
play-by-play calls I don't really feel
it it doesn't feel off balance to me you
know I can think about that someone who
was a tremendous friend and mentor to me
early in my career we overlapped for 10
years together at CBS and we all
remember summer Hall of Madden but I
also remember someone Brookshire I know
you do knew and Pat had a very special
gift for making his analyst shine and
they were transitioning at CBS from
rookie to John this is in the early 80s
and there was a really incredible bond
between Pat and Tom they did the answer
what became the the inside the NFL show
they did that together I mean they were
they were blood brothers and suddenly on
a writer asked Pat he said how do you
feel about this you're gonna miss John
on Sunday afternoon and and that said no
no in his way that he would could
stretch out a sentence for about 10
minutes but he said I'm gonna miss him
on Sunday but I'm gonna miss him more on
Saturday night and thereafter some high
jinks back in the day but you know the
whole week in the process of getting
ready for the games is this what he was
saying you know it was a joyride
and I know we had it with John to me
what a fabulous team that turned out to
be but when I think about my time in
three years of doing games with Tony
it's a continuum on Friday into Saturday
into Sunday
if all those days are the same at some
point the audience
hops in and happens to be listening to
us but we're not having just as much fun
and practice on Friday at dinner on
Friday night
same thing on Saturday we're never in a
rush we're not always talking about
football and say that might be you know
twenty percent of the time we laughing
and having just a heck of a time for a
48 hours plus and it happens to spill
over into the broadcast on Sunday
Jim Nantz the Jim Nantz line by Vineyard
Vines that store opened at Pebble Beach
last Wednesday and just steps from the
putting green across the lodge of course
Jim has outfitted us with vineyard vines
in the past and we wish you luck with
that obviously a great company and
thanks for the friendship over the years
and we truly are sad that we won't be
able to go out and and play golf in your
backyard and have breakfast out on the
on the veranda they're all kiddie
honestly it was the highlight for me
that most recent years having you guys
in some hang time with you guys but
we'll do it again sometime and the
friendship it's both ways it's treasured
with you and and all the damage is and I
hope we can chat sometimes during the
NCAA tournament
thank you Jim we will do that that's the
great Jim Nantz joining us on the
program McLovin is holding up his
hardware that he won you want it I mean
I I was horrible that day in the par-3
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]